et notre invité politique sera atteint
c'est bon car est mort un bon jour avoir
un merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
président de la région normandie
président des centres et son dépression
pendant 20 minutes pour les interviews
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représentée par
stéphane bern est bon jour ses fans
bonjour qui dirige le bureau parisien du
journal ouest france on va commencer par
les prix de l'énergie les prix de
l'énergie qui inquiète les français
hausse des prix du gaz et l électricité
et du carburant désormais le
gouvernement qui travaille sur un chèque
carburant plutôt que sur une baisse des
taxes est ce que pour vous c'est la
bonne méthode
écoutez ce qui est clair c'est qu'il
faut une réponse si on considère qu'il
s'agit d'une d'une hausse conjoncturelle
liée à la reprise d'activité économique
je pense que la proposition qui avait
été faite par valérie pécresse me semble
aller dans le bon sens c'est-à-dire la
proposer à travers la capacité pour les
entreprises de pouvoir déduire
un éventuel avantage forfait pour le
transport je pense que c'était la bonne
solution il faut quelque chose de simple
je rappelle que c'est l'état tout le
monde le sait un qui est le principal
facteur de 2 du prix du carburant parce
que ça représente à propos de mémoire 60
à 65 % du prix et donc je trouve que
eddy les salariés à travers une
contribution forfaitaire qui seraient
accordées par les entreprises est du
type c'est à mon sens la bonne idée et
ça cette idée là elle est abandonnée
c'est possible je sais rien je me
regarde je ne m'appelle pas bruno le
maire pour une contribution forfaitaire
plus un chèque essence pour les ménages
par exemple les plus magiques ménages
sont aussi d'aider des salariés quoi
enfin général - après
il faut oui mais les professions
libérales pourrez déduire aussi enfin on
peut l'imaginer par une réduction une
contribution forfaitaire des deux types
je pense que c'est un bon point est ce
que les régions présidées la région
rebondir le rappellent les régions vous
aider peuvent aider ces français à payer
leur essence est ce qu'il ya des
millions d absolument pas dans les dents
les
dans l'équation budgétaire que ça
représente si vous le faites vous moquez
de vos compatriotes ont usé bayard au
conseil régional où le houleux
rassemblement national proposé qu'on
supprime la tp est flottante c'est une
trentaine de millions d'euros de
recettes qui sont d'ailleurs fléché
puisque ça nous était accordée pour
financer le transport et notamment
transport ferroviaire
alors lendemain peut-être que
ouest-france fram un titre en dix ans la
région supprime
très bien moi je me prive de 2,35
millions d'euros ce qui est gigantesque
en termes de capacité d'investissement
puisque et de l'autre savez vous combien
ça va faire pour un normand sur son
plein représente rien du tout c'est 50
centimes d'euro sur un plat donc en
clair au bout du compte nos compatriotes
se dire on se dirait si j'avais pris
cette décision il se moque de nous qu en
quelque sorte il a fait un effet
d'annoncé en annonçant la suppression et
au bout du compte rien est-ce que c'est
pas la même mécanique qui qui est à
l'oeuvre aujourd'hui au sein du
gouvernement avec l'idée de se dire si
on touche à la ténue pp ont réduit les
taxes finalement se prive de beaucoup de
visages pour très peu d'effet enfin une
différence majeure c'est que nous on est
dieu merci obligé d'être un d'avoir un
budget à l'équilibré il tandis que là
comme vous l'avez constaté on n'a jamais
atteint des niveaux déficit aussi à
bissau je vous rappelle c'est la
première fois je crois qu'on arrive à ce
sommet du mois ce trou c'est que
aujourd'hui les grosses recettes
fiscales ne couvre que 60 % des dépenses
de l'état c'est à dire que à partir du
mois de dhou tu on peut considérer qu'on
vit à crédit sadi du jamais vu c'est à
dire que c'est un pays
où l'état
creuse une dette gigantesque donc avec
derrière des risques majeurs en cas de
hausse ou de relèvements des taux
d'intérêt ce qui n'est pas impossible
compte tenu de la résurgence de
l'inflation et de l'autre un état qui
n'investit plus le le niveau des
investissements si on enlève les
dépenses militaires ça devrait être
autour de 10 milliards ce qui est à dire
rien rien on a donc un problème
d'efficacité de l'action publique
absolument gigantesque d'où le fait
qu'il nous faut réformer réorganiser
profondément la structure publique avec
notamment un grand une grande vague d'un
grand mouvement de décentralisation pour
gagner en efficacité
pour gagner en capacité d'innovation
pour gagner en capacité de réaction ce
qu'on a d'ailleurs démontré au moment de
la crise due qu'aux villes où on a été
capable d'acheter des masques quand
l'état et est empêtrée dans ses
difficultés
[Musique]
il est temps parce que pendant cinq ans
il a été globalement celui qui a refusé
de prendre décision parce que très
clairement nucléaire lui apparaissait
comme un populaire aujourd'hui
c'est quand même un d'ailleurs un
retournement assez incroyable c'est que
nos compatriotes à nouveau sont
favorables au nucléaire probablement en
raison d' indépendance énergétique et
aussi en raison d'une immense âme c'est
qu'on ne peut pas lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique efficacement au
21e 500 le nucléaire et puis par
ailleurs qu'elle serait l'énergie de
substitution on voit bien que sur les
éoliennes on est exactement dans le
nimby c'est à dire qu'il ya encore une
majorité de français qui veulent de
l'éolien mais certainement pas au pied
leur jardin et ils ont raison parce que
le massacre des paysages par l'éolien
terrestre massif qui envahit toutes nos
campagnes pour moi c'est absolument
inacceptable
on le fait dans des parcs éoliens
concentrés dans des lieux où on nuit le
moins possible quand vous êtes en
normandie que vous êtes dans un un un
territoire et une région dans laquelle
l'habitat est très dispersé oui encore
des bocages fantastique vous allez pas
mettre une néo lienne derrière un
derrière une haie tout ça tout ça pour
globalement enrichir quelques
entreprises privées qui se font du fric
avec ça et qui n'ont absolument rien à
des dégâts sur les paysages et
l'environnement ensuite et dernier
élément que souvent on oublie de citer
c'est que
quand on entend en permanence la
question de l'artificialisation des
terres
pour produire de l'énergie électrique
avec de l'éolien le rapport entre le
nucléaire et l'éolien sa rapport de 1 à
2 cents c'est à dire qu'on
artificialisés 202 on artificialisés 200
fois plus pour produire la même énergie
quand il s'agit d'énergie
liées à l'éolien terrestre alors si le
si l'éolien se développent moins prévu
est ce que ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut
garder les centrales nucléaires ouverte
il y en a il ya 12 fermetures prévues
est ce qu'un président qui change d'avis
sur nucléaire c'est un président qui
peut revenir en arrière aussi sur ce
type de délit ce que je sais c'est qu'il
nous faut des ep r comme vous le savez
la normandie a été désigné par edf
compte tenu compte tenu du consensus
politique et notre volonté en milieu rap
écologie les verts de nous trouve
volonté d'accueillir deuxième père c'est
à penly c'est en seine maritime
nous avons premier avec flamanville
gildas encore la semaine dernière avec
tous les élus quelle que soit leur
couleur politique de la région dieppoise
voilà c'est enfin ou pire le pays
aujourd'hui après tout
c'est très très confuse et le même débat
que sur les questions de défense que je
connais encore un peu
c est ce que nous maintenons notre base
industrielle et technologique en matière
de défense quoi qu'il arrive on sait une
chose c'est que si on perd notre base
industrielle et technologique on n'est
pas capable de construire nous outil
militaire de demain et d'après demain et
bien là on a perdu notre base
industrielle et technologique en partie
parce qu'on n'a plus construit de
centrales nucléaires et donc il nous
faut acquérir à nouveau cette compétence
ce savoir faire et ses flamanville qui
paie en erronée d'ambarès de le faire
c'est apporter je crois enfin si j'en
crois ce que on a pu me dire la semaine
dernière dans le cotentin on est en
train de deux doigts de réussir ce que
nous a demandé la haute autorité sur le
père est ce que ça veut dire que vous
êtes aussi très confiant vous êtes
raisonnablement confiant concernant le
projet de minicentrale
ou parce que la
technologie n'existe pas mais enfin je
ne suis pas technicien mais mais m je
pense qu'elle est assez comparable à ce
qu'on est capable de faire sur des sous
marins à propulsion nucléaire pense
qu'on doit être à peu près dans des
choses assez combrailles a un vrai
savoir faire français dans qui a un
savoir-faire français qui est tenu par
une entreprise s'appelle technicatome
d'ailleurs et donc
je me souviens pour tout vous dire d'une
visite en chine où on m'avait demandé
pour une entreprise chinoise qui est
présente dans le puits dans plusieurs
usines en normandie il fallait que
j'aille ils les voir pour pour une
d'entre elles et
j'avais les autorités chinoises m'avait
demandé de pouvoir les rencontrer et
j'ai été étonné c'est quoi pas étonné
mais enfin il m'avait dit mais nous on
veut construire 200 mini centrale au
bord de nos côtes vous avez la
technologie en france donc pour eux j'ai
la technologie c'était ce qu'on était
capable de faire sur le sous-marin à
propulsion nucléaire ce qui est
inconcevable que nous puissions donner
cette technologie aux chinois bientôt un
dernier mot là dessus et après on va
changer de sujet mais tout à l'heure
vous nous avez fait part de votre
inquiétude sur la dette sur les déficits
qu'on vous voyaient déjà le coup de le
père de flamanville est sauf mais pas
inquiet sur le coup mais ses pairs mais
non parce que là parce que parce que je
vous dis on y suit simplement les
plâtres d'une nouvelle technologie
qui sur laquelle on a perdu une partie
des compétences mais ses compétences on
est on les reprend et puis vous vous
rendez compte pour un territoire comme
la normandie
le deuxième paire à penly savez vous ce
que ça représente comme activité 15
milliards d'euros dix mille emplois
c'est un défi territoriale gigantesque
parce qu'il faut mettre en place ces
équipements qui conviennent les
infrastructures faire en sorte que nous
puissions développer les compétences
parce que quand vous avez dix mille
salariés de plus sur un bassin d'emploi
de 40 milles vous vous rendez compte que
ça présente un défi donc on est déjà en
train de bosser sur toutes ces questions
d'où le fait que la normandie et été
choisi par edf pourquoi parce que il ya
un consensus politique de cécile
collectivités locales disent non on n'en
veut pas vous voyez bien que ça devient
un défi impossible
oui les députés aujourd'hui vont se
pencher sur le texte concernant la le
prolongement de l'état d'urgence la
crise sanitaire
avec la question du pass sanitaire est
ce que vous faites partie des gens qui
pensent faire un qui pense qu'il faut
prolonger le pass sanitaires et si oui
jusqu'à ce que parce que franchement ça
nous emmerdent
vous pose la question coûte et moi je
vous le présenter dix fois par jour diot
sic je suis attentif aux questions des
libertés fondamentales et libertés
individuelles c'est pour moi
en permanence j'ai été opposé quand
j'étais mise défense au fichier edvige
par exemple que claude guéant avait
voulu instaurer bien
mais franchement oui vous voulez que je
vous dit quelque chose la
capacité de contradictions des français
est tellement étant tellement
gigantesques que je suis convaincu que
le jour où il ne sera plus obligatoire
je pense qu'il ya des restaurants qui en
feront un instrument marketing en disant
nous alors nous nous on va demander pour
vous protéger vous voyez bon c'est
évident qu'un jour il faudra s'en
séparer mais pas d'une suite mais bon
est-ce que ça pose un problème est-ce
que vous ai le sentiment tous les matins
de 2,2 de vivre un quart et un côté
insupportable quand vous allez dans un
bistrot de vous demander le pass
sanitaires et puis de
laissons voir un peu comment évolue la
crise et khoualed épidémie et puis
deuxièmement franchement les les
atteintes aux nôtres traçabilité elle ne
repose paraît que là dessus
malheureusement est ce qu a contrario
vous seriez favorable à alléger les
mesures dans les régions où est
carrément dit par exemple normandie
quasiment pas d'épidémie
on est la région la mieux vacciner de
france et donc du coup énorme ans très
digitimes east c'est un peu
trouvé que c'est une bonne idée où il ya
un risque de passer à côté d'une reprise
épidémie qu'on le voit déjà beaucoup
moins thèse du coup il vendre un bon
souvent ce sont ceux qui refusent de se
faire vacciner quoi voilà et puis
honnêtement si vous partez en vacances
vous devez avoir les moyens de pouvoir
vous faire tester quoi facilement ou
partie par lacombe avait su réponse
ailleurs on va parler d'un sujet qui
concerne de près à la normandie c'est le
sujet de la pêche la pêche et le bric
site le problème toujours pas réglé
comment est-ce que vous l'expliquer
écoutez moi je suis allée agir et ya
trois semaines j'avais eu des mots très
durs avec le premier ministre jersey ce
comme vous savez
jersey est en situation d'autonomie donc
à part leur politique étrangère la
politique de défense y sont autonomes en
tout
et parce que pendant une période ils ont
joué un double jeu ou un drôle de jeu
bien on s'est parlé on s'est parlé
franchement en fait et j'aurais dit
écoutez c'est assez simple il faut
revenir à l'accord à l'esprit de
l'accord de granville qui est celui qui
régit les droits de pêche dans les eaux
guernesey et jersey est bon c'est quoi
les pêcheurs qui pêchait dans ces eaux
doivent avoir le droit de pêcher c'est
ce qui était prévu et bien la plupart
d'entre eux c'est le cas il reste un
certain nombre de licence provisoire sur
lesquels il ya trois mois pour donner
des dernières preuves et moi j'ai dit au
premier ministre chargé d où les bateaux
en question vous les connaissez vous
nous c'est dans nos eaux territoriales
sortez la liste sortez la liste de tous
les bateaux qui pêchaient avant est
considéré que c'est votre référence je
dis comme ça on ne vous prêtera pas un
double jeu qui consiste en fait à
évincer un sombre de pêcheurs mais
franchement
dans la liste je vous parlais
honnêtement il y à un certain nombre de
bateaux qui ont demandé de la pêche qui
pêchaient pas donc en fait on a deux
sujets le premier ce sont ce qu'on
appelle les bateaux neufs c'est à dire
ceux qui ont été les nouveaux bateaux
que des pêcheurs ont acheté et qui bien
entendu non pas de référence parce
qu'ils sont exit est en construction
mais avec des pêcheurs qui allait pêcher
donc j'ai dit au premier ministre jersey
attribué ce droit de pêche aux pêcheurs
et pas simplement bateau pour régler
cette question des bateaux neufs et puis
il ya un ou deux bateaux qui ont été
interdits compass pu pêcher pour des
raisons de deux problématiques que
juridictionnelle un pont ça comme ça
pour pour faire court et qui eux aussi
doivent pouvoir pêcher mais on peut pas
demander jeudi à aux autorités jersey
guernesey d'accorder le droit de pêche à
des bateaux qui pêchaient pas voilà
c'est ce que est ce que ce qu'il faut
retenir de tout ça que c'est le problème
est enfin en passe d'être réglés ou pas
je joue nous on est pas mal nous les
normands on est plutôt pas mal servi
mais on a aussi notre histoire à nous je
vous rappelle que les îles
anglo-normandes
utilisent encore le droit normand qu'il
est a pris à l'université de cambrai
normand par une universitaire formidable
s'appelle sophie poiret bien que vous ne
peut que la charte du la charte aux
normands est là encore
existence à guernesey est bon donc on a
notre histoire à nous avec les îles
anglo-normandes on s'appelle les cousins
il parle encore français il parle
souvent normand qu'on nous ne parlons
plus bon
jeu donc moi juge trouve assez légitime
quand on est ce dialogue nous normands
puisque on a notre histoire on va parler
de la présidentielle pour terminer
comment vous avez ressenti des
républicains d'exclure les centres et la
désignation d'un idiot
ça vous a mis en colère non faussée je
vous assure près comme diot parce que
quand on comme le disait le priant de la
commission des lois juste avant quand on
veut construire une majorité dans la
construit la plus large possible et
honnêtement au conti a bien d une
formation politique qui a été
fidèle solide moi j'ai rappelé et ces
éléments là quelques leader des
républicains
je leur ai dit moi quand françois fillon
était en campagne quand toi tu te
planquer moi je suis allé faire campagne
jusqu'au bout moi je suis allé faire des
meetings françoise à vie à bellamy qu'à
d'autres quand toi tu étais resté à la
maison bon donc chez soi on fait preuve
de beaucoup plus de courage qui a un
certain nombre de mes camarades qui sont
aux républicains une prison pour vous
mais pas une crise ont ils le choix sera
fait et puis et plus christian jacob
ouais mais je suis bon en finition il
était contre les primaires et christian
il a organisé
vous les barons et la paye baroin saleh
de sarkozy zapater sarkozy bon voilà il
veut que xavier bertrand est ce qu'on
dit ouais c'est ce qu'en dit flux d
annoncer qu il voulait vous le parti
veut présenter un candidat à la
présidentielle rendez vous et moi
on est des gens
formidables et est donc
[Musique]
écoutez moi je sais ce que ça représente
pression ce soir c'est une façon de
faire pression sur le régime syrien et
quand on n'est rien
quand on venait entre 0 et 0,5 quoi
enfin voilà quoi donc
très clairement
aujourd'hui l'imaginaire mais oui c'est
pas pareil l'élection présidentielle
voit bien qu'il faut pas un parti
politique zemmour il après deux partis
politiques
vous voyez bien que soit vous rentrez
dans une construction politique qui fait
que vous êtes dans l'imaginaire
collectif et donc à vous est légitime
pour vous présenter mes et si vous
n'êtes pas dans cet imaginaire et donc
c'est une longue construction ça que ça
veut dire et donc ça se décide pas en
mois d'octobre
si vous n'êtes pas dans cet imaginaire
j'ai pas la peine vous ne réussirez pas
à pas par rapport à l'ensemble des
candidats qui se présentent à la
primaire des républicains est ce qu'il y
en a certains qui ne sont absolument pas
centriste compatible non on peut pas
dire ça pour pas dire ça c'est d'autant
plus difficile à dire pour le
candidat voterez d'abord on laisse
passer les primaires 1 voilà
un peu ça vous le savez bien ce qu'est
la presse m moi je soutiens une
candidate très sérieuse
qui fait pas de la démagogie matin midi
soir et nuit
je suis sûr vous allez me poser de
questions je trouve que globalement
c'est assez sérieux c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs
la question
parce que dans l'état dans lequel est le
pays
il faut pouvoir incarner une rupture on
continue sur ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure et des candidatures qui
émergeraient
le pays dans un tel état que si vous
n'incarnez pas une rupture vous avez
beaucoup de mal à être entendu mais ce
que j'aime en valérie pécresse sait que
c'est sérieux c'est solide
vous savez
moi j'ai fait beaucoup de sauts mais
quand j'étais au gouvernement avec le
présent la république j'étais à la riaj
donc j'étais c'était bien j'observais on
n'a pas besoin forcément d'avoir des
chefs d'état de gouvernement qui qui qui
qui voilà qui en impose par baring ce
dont a besoin cette personne qui soit
sérieuse solide quand vous croisiez et
angela merkel
elle vous impressionnait pas je peux
vous les normands qui fait beaucoup
parler mais c'est edouard philippe est
ce que vous aimez est ce que vous vous
regardez du côté des douars fini ps
qu'il peut attirer à lui les centristes
des cieux écouter et leur philippe il
est au sein de la majorité
présidentielle nous il peut partir du
mot merci nous nous n'y sommes pas donc
voilà alors il est dans il est dans sa
construction personnelle mais
voilà bon après la vie politique elle
est appelée à bouger mais
mais aujourd'hui ceux qui font le choix
de dorison
sont des gens qui font partis qui
soutiennent emmanuel macron rien n'a
beaucoup je suis vous la poutre travail
non vraiment franchement mon personnel
tenter de changer
j'ai pas mal de copains qui sont allés
pour voir à c'était juste pour voir oui
et j'ai été curieux alors voilà ils ont
vu en prison j'ai quoi les ont vus mais
module n'était pas
bonne dynamique en tout cas dont les
sondages comment vous l'expliquez
comment qualifiez vous et moi
j'ai dit qu'on dit non elle n'est pas
candidate n'ont ils pas conduire à mon
sens bon
il faut enfin je vois pas bien où vous
vous êtes sûr où vous bras il pourrait
ne pas aller au bout si site d'un coup
la course à versoix et ce qui est
impossible on a eu à chaque élection
présidentielle
on a eu la période chevènement enfin
pourrait leur faire dix fois par contre
avec la dynamique est la sienne il aura
ses signatures des finances ancien
facilement ces signatures je suis
rappelé un maire qui donc ça pour être
les sondages qui font avec ses marques à
ce qu'elle représente
on peut pas faire campagne simplement
sur le sur la
sur la question de l'immigration
d'identité bon ces sujets cela sont des
sujets profonds et d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça que ça parle aux français mais il a
aucun programme quoi 20 et puis là
quelle expérience et c'est pas je veux
pas renoncer pas parce qu'on est
journaliste que pour autant tout d'un
coup bien pris à un public qu enfin et
puis alors vous pose cette question
quelle équipe
qui l'a gouvernement on reprend des
amateurs à nouveau
je sais que emmanuel macron a fait
l'éloge des amateurs et n'est pas qu'on
a vu
non mais c'est lui même qui a dit moi je
suis content d'être d'abord une majorité
d'amateurs je suis plus qu'il avait dit
un truc de jambon
soyez fiers d'être des amateurs ben moi
je pense l'inversé
voilà
quand les bons gouvernements sont des
gouvernements avec des gens qui ont de
l'expérience et qui ont l'intuition des
français quand vous avez emmanuelle
wargon
qui vous dit que
c'est une erreur je suis plus quels sont
ses mots sur la maison individuelle
d'accord enfin ok mais des conneries
comme ça on n'a pas besoin d entendre
quoi pardon
pardon elle même qui doit vivre dans une
maison j'imagine dans un bon quartier de
paris
bon on est dans une bon honnêtement
expliquer aux français que ce qui est le
rêve de bon nombre de familles ça doit
être désormais bannis et concentrer les
gens dans des immeubles ok ça ce genre
de choses vous l'éviter quand vous avez
des femmes et des hommes qu'on
d'expérience qui savent ce que c'est que
suffrage universel merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]